I think music is a notion you will just
keep going on and you're gonna kind of
you know happiness and fulfillment
journey for life indeed you find
yourself in London we're told you're
performing a greatest hits concert
tomorrow at the o2 but of course
tomorrow also Indian Independence Day
why have you had chosen to spend it here
with us in the UK rather than back at
home I think it was a perfect perfect
date and to celebrate Independence Day
because a lot of history about England
and India and it's a friendly notion and
I've been working in England for almost
15 years starting from Bombay Dreams and
a lot of the Rings musical on stage
Danny Boyle so and we have a great crowd
here amazing as you see a huge amount of
history shared history between the UK
and India do you think relations have
been restored between our two countries
given that at the former colonial
imperialist past
in many cases we have to keep moving on
and remember the good things and I feel
there's a perfect opportunity to do that
there's so many things they can share
knowledge wisdom love music and
tomorrow's gonna be a musical night
we're told that this is going to be a
compilation of your greatest x-men first
question with a career spanning two
decades a hundred soundtracks a couple
of Oscars thrown into the mix I mean
have an FD you narrow it down to music
for just one night at the or two
the is a very tough thing to do but I go
with my instinct and I feel like I just
did a tour back in the US last month on
the intimate tour and then we went with
instinct again because certain songs
become iconic in part of the history of
people's lives and so I select from that
there's been such a crossover between
Bollywood's eastern countries in general
and Western culture how was your music
evolved since you first started out in
the business I started in the South I
added tamil movie called Raja which was
dubbed in Hindi and I didn't know that
he it will cross over to him the first
of all it was dumb and many movies
started getting dub Bombay was done and
I think for me what I believe is that
that music should be for all and I loved
western music I loved Eastern music and
I wanted my music to be having the same
philosophy and that happened and even
working with in Hollywood or London it's
the same philosophy and there's so many
things we can share and it all requires
a bit of connecting in small steps I
guess